j'ai eu très lassant tiers des questions
qui attire marina alex vous connaissez
le principe de jean luc lemoine sur ce
qui l'attend ah ouais et malheureusement
on va prendre les choses sur l'équipe
merci en tout cas voir in à merci et
nora vous avez été bien courageuse
surtout et noah en train de défiler mais
c'était chaud qu'on va avoir beaucoup de
4-5 ans y aller tout de suite une
question bonjour je m'appelle jules nous
sommes en plein mercato télé et pourtant
personne n'essaie de recruter les gens
de votre équipe
est ce que parce qu'ils sont trop nuls
ça rit c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser jules sommes-nous une équipe de
tocards m'a peut-être mais mais peu
importe l'essentiel c'est que nous
soyons une vraie équilibré mais c'est
vrai tous l'année prochaine c'est tout
il aura des nouveautés mais il pas
encore les anciens restent tous les
anciens restent mais non on est une
vraie équipe va souder par l'amour
l'entraidé le respect au volant il n'y a
pas de vanne mais non mais par exemple
je donne un exemple il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine
valérie bénaïm avait envie d'assister à
la finale de roland garros oui seul
problème elle n'avait pas de place
heureusement elle a un ami qui a le bras
long
dimanche face à face à bath et roland
jourdain majeurs dont genève
le match est relancé le grand chelem à
eric tu agis suis pas allé au sort doit
aussi près de la bouche il adore sa
juste place bon finalement valérie
rester chez elles oui parce que moment
de sa demande elle avait des aphtes mais
pas seulement pour faire allez tous en
ce moment sur lui comme nvidia
en fait ça à cause d'une question de
physique et n'y a pas été veux tu peux
dire la vérité et ça c'est c'est jean
michel qui nous l'a expliqué non
évidemment
julien écriture parfois jean-michel
égalant ouais bah preuve voilà c'est
pour ça c'est bon c'est bon
pas très bien français mais c'est plutôt
sympa janvier des cadeaux il est bon il
valait dans les anges mais sinon tout va
faire s'arrête là et pas un truc à part
les cats hier j'ai c'est d'être honnête
pour dévoiler le vrai visage de mes
camarades fois ci sont sympas je montre
aussi manger comme vous montrer ce qui
s'est passé sur les faux culs de la
semaine à titi jean-michel sa part d'une
histoire de pellicule
c'est le toit pas de plage soit géant
numérique les faits très longtemps
il
c'est corrigé mais tout s'est pourtant
valérie jean michel ne flatte que cyril
on l'a vu dans le dernier palmarès
alors je n'avais pas tout mis la semaine
dernière à cannes j'en voulais encore en
travaux j'avais un peu de rab
une seule prise une seule prise
extraordinaire je t'ai vu tu comprenais
pas et tout ça sans prompteur
la grande classe
dans sa tête mais c'est normal que c'est
sa vénérée cas c'est un bosseur mais je
vous rendent hommage c'est un bosseur
comme je n'ai jamais vu pendant les pubs
alors que nous nous reposons et bien lui
ibos et il parle avec la régie un moment
volé dans l'intimité de ce grand homme
et dites-moi est-ce que je peux avoir un
morceau de votre cuche admet jérôme et
moi ça ta beauté de dévisser dans ce
débat sérieux et dis moi c'est ça parce
que je prends un petit ton cul oui en
fait pendant les pauses savoir cyril
fait deux choses ils demandent des
morceaux de cul et il chante
car s'ils aiment les chansons à textes
qu'il connaît par coeur il ya moi
j'adore toupie
dowd où ils sont dix noms comme tout
partout ils font attention aux traces
j'ai vérifié les paroisses et attention
aux farces attention tracé ça manque
entre shopping le doubs en gastro grave
on va vous dire la vérité on n'en peut
plus de vos chansons
non mais c'est vrai alors certains en
équipe arrive à le cacher d'autres un
petit peu moins il est content mais si
tu vois qu'il est content je sais pas ce
qui est pire chamerois excédé ou benhaim
qui parle de séries comme de son petit
frère attardé
heureusement en syrie n'a besoin de
personne pour se valoriser et sait déjà
qu'un jour on écrira un livre sur lui
me collard il revient je serais vous je
confierais pas bio et n'aura non en fait
il faut faire comme jean-michel alors
lui il s'embête pas il va l'écrire
lui-même son bouquin non si il y en a eu
l'idée le jour on recevait william
leymergie pour son livre les dents du
bonheur un bonheur
dans les gares
deux heures c'est les victimes d'abus
deux ans
oh la la moi je vous rassure il ya quand
même des gens qui bossent dans cette wii
va commencer par la meilleure d'entre
nous qu'est jabel mort d'isabelle morini
bosc est ce qui est bien c'est qu'elle a
toujours un truc à dire le seul problème
c'est qu'on me donne jamais la parole
donc elle parle tout seul tout de suite
les bichons parallèle et 10
le pas
c'est pas une compétition qu'on arrête
la compétition pour l'un des deux oui
mais maintenant aussi maintenant m
non mais voilà c'est le trip
si monsieur est bien
elle semblait problèmes connexes et
caleb la menthe oncle émission c'est à
dire que tout est comme ça donc à moi on
veut pas toujours lui donnait
apparemment non mais c'est pas facile
well as déjà pour prendre la parole mais
aussi à cause de ce qu'elle a vécu en
coulisses qu'est ce qu'il ya elle l'a
révélé dans une précédente cas tiers
pour lui faire une blague
cyril avait trempé son
son copain moustachu dans un dans un
verre et avait même posé une casquette
dessus croyez le ou non si l'image sont
gravés à jamais dans la mémoire
d'isabelle lé pas traumatisée elle est
juste admirative alors la séquence
suivante j'ai longtemps hésité à la
mettre dans les discussion surréaliste
finalement je me suis dit que c'était
surtout un bon moyen d'en savoir plus
sur le mystérieux kasserine
on
de mémoire de beewi
mais les proportions
n'oubliez pas de tuque la location mais
on parle pendant les pauses oui c'est
normal me viendra désormais le porte
manteau
allez une autre question bonjour je
m'appelle ludivine d'autres soir j'ai
croisé jean michel maire dans la rue je
suis resté immobile pour ne pas exciter
mais il m'a quand même fait un sourire
que faut-il faire dans ces cas là c'est
une question qu'on me pose souvent
ludivine quels sont les gestes à adopter
si on croise jean michel bertrand la rue
déjà je vous conseille de lever les bras
au dessus de votre tête comme pour les
autres les chaînes aura l'impression que
vous êtes plus grande que vous l'êtes en
réalité et le rappeur et surtout surtout
ne le touchez jamais même sans le faire
exprès ça déclenche immédiatement son
regard de vicelard la preuve avec
l'entrée sur notre plateau de julia
vignali qui a eu le temps de légèrement
l'effleuré regarder
face à jean michel tu le touches et que
tu veux coucher avec lui le problème
c'est que parfois ce sont des mecs
qu'ils touchent comme ici gary dourdan a
sur ce coup
les musiques
oui
j'ai couché avec toi de toi mais c'est
comme ça alors vous savez cyril a
récemment remonté les bretelles de jean
michel a crié reproché quoi de préparer
son émission de radio pendant la télé et
ça ça passe pas ça ne passe pas il le
sait mais saïd a compris la leçon espère
résultats et jean-michel ne bouge plus
d'oreilles pour le plus grand bonheur de
cyril je connaissais pas du tout qu'il y
ait une 30e sortir maintenant tu vois
jean messer il a peur de rien c'est ça
c'est ça le problème
mais dans son contrat aidé à placer le
moteur dans une phrase sur deux mais
revenons aux règles de sécurité
concernant jean michel
si vous venez dans notre public mettez
un poncho hk oui ou n'importe quoi qui
quittent vous aime être pas trop en
valeur car pendant les pubs qu'est-ce
que vous pourrez qu'il fait oui mesdames
et messieurs c'est une machine
sacré talent là tu as le concept
un petit peloton
métro qui rentre la bleue la zone
amériques qui plombe la vague des
ménages ne voient pas les grandes
batailles complètement dingue
jabulani charrette cutting excusez nous
excuser le public wii et qui excite et
qu'elles n'ont alors je sais dans le mec
de lâche rien il va dire que j'exagère
un peu que je caricature on va voir on
va vérifier on va voir si on peut lui
parler d'autre chose
de suite les nouvelles aventures de jean
michel et c'est pour toi
c'est jimmy roye très déçu le gars dont
je parlais musicale hair la question ah
oui alors bonjour je m'appelle jeanine
j'aime beaucoup les caniches
mais je trouve ça un peu cher donc je
voulais savoir est ce que christophe
carrière compte bientôt nous faire une
portée
oh